sí muy buenos días pues francia como
usted bien lo indicaba denuncia que el
50 por ciento de las licencias que ya se
habían acordado pues todavía no han sido
entregadas a los pesqueros franceses es
decir son cerca de
244 la disputa también está sobre los
diferentes documentos y justificativos
que deben presentar los barcos pesqueros
franceses para obtener esas licencias
eso ellos deben demostrar que antes del
haber éxito ellos ya pescaban en esas
aguas pero los problemas han sido sobre
todo para los pequeños barcos sobre todo
en esas islas del canal como jr siguen
sí porque son barcos pequeños que a
veces no cuentan por ejemplo con datos
de gps o datos satelitales y por eso
muchas veces han visto sus licencias
revocadas de aquellos que pescan sobre
ese en esas aguas y al menos 45 que no
han podido trabajar que no han podido
salir al mar desde desde el pasado mes
de abril por esto francia pues se
considera que el reino unido no ha
mantenido
lo que se había acordado y por eso el
día de ayer el portavoz del gobierno
indicó que van a tomar medidas de
retorsión que deben entrar en vigor a
partir del próximo martes 2 de noviembre
a menos de que la situación pues se
mejore estas medidas son fuese un
aumento en los en los controles
aduaneros pero también sanitarios así
como la prohibición de todo barco
pesquero británico de atracar en puerto
francés y dijeron que en caso de que la
situación continúa deteriorándose pues
francés ya tiene listo un segundo
paquete de medidas que podría implicar
problemas para el suministro de energía
a estas islas del canal